hi my name is Frank shitake I'm part of
the IBM cloud team I'm here to explain
some basic network concepts that are
pretty ubiquitous are universally used
and the terms are nat and firewall and
let's start off with nat nap stands for
network address translation it's
described in an IETF RFC 1918 and what
natin really does is allows us to
translate Internet addresses to private
address space and private address space
is really there because there's only a
finite number of Internet TCP IP
addresses so to cover this topic I
always find it's better to use analogies
and we're going to use the apartment
analogy to describe what an internal
network or TCP IP ranges versus an
external tcp/ip range so over here we
have our apartments apartment buildings
we have apartment building one we have
apartment building - okay and within
those apartments we have apartment
buildings we have apartment 1 2 3 4 etc
and over our apartment building - well
lo and behold we have the same apartment
numbers ok the only thing that really
differentiates apartment 1 and building
to an apartment a 1 in building 1 is
their street address so much like an
internet tcp/ip address the street
address is uniquely addressable across
the world right so we have apartment 1
is let's say I don't know 1 2 3 Street
first Street and apartment 2 is 1 5 7
second Street okay so those addresses
the street address is uniquely
addressable across the world or as the
apartments themselves the apartment
numbers
are not unique so that really describes
the difference between an internal 1918
tcp/ip address and an external address
well how do you get between those two
things you get there by something called
nat network address translation nat is
typically used to translate an IP
address from one range or multiple IP
addresses from one range to an IP
address on some other range it's
commonly used between private internal
networks and an internet IP address
because those are finite and
subsequently they can be very expensive
to purchase or to use right so in the
case of apartment in one we have a
device that does our netting and the
second part of this topic is firewalls a
NAT device typically goes along with a
firewall function and it's usually
employed and in some kind of a routing
device a routing device connects two or
more computer what networks so we're
just gonna put our firewall down here in
both our apartment's here so in that
firewall okay so let's say someone in
apartment 2 wants to communicate or send
a letter I mean a mail
remember those mail over to company 1
net and he wants to send it out over you
know from his street address to the
company 1 street address or let's just
say from his internal IP address to a
public IP address or an internet IP
address what he would do is send that
out to the nanning device which is akin
to let's say you have a home router
running device that's the first device
your traffic's going to hit the nat
network address translation part of that
is going to convert that internal
address to a real internet address which
is what it's this 1 2 3 first street
that traffic is gonna traverse from 1 2
3 first Street so it's like sending a
mail with the return address being 1 2 3
first Street over to company 1 net as
soon as company 1 net sends a response
it's going to not send it to apartment
two it's actually going to send it to
one two three first Street all right
that's gonna send a response back and
what's gonna happen is then the nanning
device actually keeps track of what's
going out and the respond corresponding
response and it knows that the response
to one two three first street let's say
it's the person's name they put their
name on the the letter going out it
knows it converts that to an internal
address which happens to be apartment
two it knows that person lives in
apartment two
here's the key company one doesn't know
that that person lives in apartment two
all it knows is one two three first
street essentially obscuring the final
address of that person so by that it's
kind of a security device because it
protects that it protects that person
it's akin to a security device now that
by itself is typically not enough on the
same device will have a firewall
function what's a firewall function a
firewall function is known as a security
device service appliance that actually
monitors the network communication
between the source some source and some
destination typically deployed across
two different networks that's not always
the case but in this analogy we're gonna
just say the firewall is there between
the internal network and the external
network and notice we have it deployed
with our NAT device so on a typical
firewall we'll have something called the
very first firewall with something
called a stateless stateless firewall
and all the stateless firewall is it's
just like a lock on the door so we put a
lock over here and we put a lock over
here well that says is I'm a person that
wishes to get into the department I have
a key I'll open the door and go in well
it's not a bad way to go it keeps most
people out of the apartment building
that don't live there but somebody can
tailgate and they can go in behind that
behind that traffic maybe they
you're out the key there's a couple
different ways it's a decent firewall
but as things get more sophisticated
it's not enough so the next type of
firewall that came up was called
stateful I love my writing so a stateful
firewall does this now we've hired a
security guard right here's our security
guard he's a cool dude he's sitting at
the front desk
so as traffic tries to enter the
apartment building maybe they have a key
he looks at the person and says where
are you going I'm going to apartment I'm
going to apartment four okay so now that
traffic's allowed two apartment four
doesn't ask what the person's doing
there or anything else just allows the
traffic so really a stateful firewall
will allow understands the the source
and destination of the traffic and it
actually monitors the conversation
between that source and destination and
does a little bit more being a traffic
cop between those two source and
destination so last thing we're going to
look at is something called an
application firewall and this is
application there you go application
firewall is something that looks deeper
at the conversation so now we have our
our traffic cop over here and what he's
doing is now rather than just asking
what apartment you're going to he's
gonna ask what your purpose is right and
so think of it this way it actually
looks deeper into the conversation if
we're talking about webs service traffic
and make sure that's really type web
type traffic that's being communicated
from the source and destination not just
some other type of traffic that could
meant to be know let's say some kind of
malicious traffic so in other words it's
analogous to
okay I have a person trying to get to
apartment two and that person says that
they're there to deliver a pizza when
really you know they're trying to do
door-to-door sales so the security cop
or a security guard in this case would
figure that out and not allow the person
to enter the department and those are
the basics of natty and firewalling
thank you for watching this video if you
have any questions please drop us a line
if you would like to see more videos
like this in the future be sure to LIKE
and subscribe